[Music]
really
this is Captain Steve bounty I am out
here in an island alone Mayday Mayday
Mayday
my [__] rocket ship has gone down
Mayday Mayday Mayday
[Music]
my rocket ship has gone down if there's
any life-form or civilization please hit
me back
[Music]
what the [__] you take it the only cuts
artist April Fool's is over get your
life together you jerk loss April Fool
get the [__] out here uncle Joey here
dropping knowledge on your mother
[__] on an early Saturday morning
April 2nd 2016 the [__] have you done
you understand me
we got the [__] weed of debt some
people asked me I came by brain my main
man never [__] Dugga Dugga another
sort of farms what do you [__] Nazi
dropped off some gorillas blue number
for this [__] could [__] barrel has a
meal that you're stabbing in this
damaged
you know how we do 7:24 stone till it
deals no pills nor how Paul no nothing
just trade up the [__] reefer from
debt what are you doing tonight you're
busy if not come down a [__] brain
prob
we take some breads where I [__]
started this little revolution about ten
years ago it's a little [__] town off
the 57 tremendous little comedy club
there was savages last time people will
high my main man brought me [__] the
Allman Brothers live from the Fillmore
East I got [__] of Tony Bennett I got
pink floor I mean come on it's on fire
down there brave you're not down there
tonight you're [__] slipping call
call I don't give a [__] seven one four
four eight two zero seven hundred tell
him you're [__] coming down the sling
dick and get stoned to the measles if
not stay home do whatever the [__] you
do a little Bob huh look at me I'm in
VIP even three I think that's what you
don't may I be your VI dick
my little professional poker it's a
beautiful day to be alive here we'll
make it happen tonight
I can't call a digital little much more
from cannot bounce around get a little
vitamin D some sit-ups and then I had to
go go [__] thing I gotta learn I
don't run I gotta meet these [__]
jerk-offs and then to shows embrace
seven nine [__] thirty and
that's it [__] it's a beautiful
day to be alive the sun shining the
birds chirping the most importantly
you're alive you could be in a [__]
casket there but hey like I always say
John Lennon is dead then I don't feel so
[__] good myself you know I'm saying
work that hang them what's to say to
they hang out much to do we're just
gonna get stoned watch the final for
North Carolina looks good there's a
couple teams and there look good and
that's it what do you want from me
people ain't your [__] Julie McCoy I
ain't your [__] that town coordinator
you want to come to Brad
you come to Brad you want to [__]
smoke dope you smoke dope you want to go
to a little party and get [__] in a
muffle that's your concerns
those are your businesses you know I'm
saying me I'm gonna take it easy little
[__] we wanna get will [__] it you
know get it together Syracuse Jimbo I've
been looking at that [__] for
like four years when I was a kid he was
coaching coaching you know which weaves
very nice my man [__] throw some nice
[__] reefer look at these stems here
all good
Hey
look at this can you do this
[__] Hitler if he was Jamaican often
me mr. no losers smoking dope [__]
around with your people to be humble it
could be the mailman could be anybody
you know I love you [__] really
got me like I've had this something
wrong before judging I'm hot here
[__] trying to be you see me out here
trying to be something I'm not
come on fella just gets high there's a
podcast and we all have a good [__]
time that's it that's what I want from
you [__] [__] about the
craziness the air this [__] most people
care but you know what I give it from
the back smokin some dope can be in the
best person I could be every day a
little bit every day I'm saying just a
little bit not good
you can still [__] up you still call
somebody [__] your mother son's
dick whatever we got to say
Oh
these dyes that are beautiful there's a
way you get some [__] another heart form
just get there I don't give a [__] if
you gotta become Amish there's this weed
here this gorilla glue number four once
they start using numbers that's when
it's a different game when it was just a
chore with my sister I call it number
two in the seventies number three why
don't know just a [__] fat goober from
North Bergen New Jersey for me anyway
vitamin D is the key I'm lead slow lunch
with my family and just right outside
just right that's it when the time is
right out do ten sets of swings I'll do
some cleans I'll do some [__] squats
I do some [__] sit-ups some push-ups
some [__] bridges and that's it guys
I'm 50 I'm not trying to prove then I'm
just an old [__] man swinging
definitely even I bubbled up I'm saying
when I was your age
I wish I thought I've been [__] just
be dead by 53 but I'm here so I gotta
make it that that's it if you're here
you better make it happen does this
whole [__] that mean you gotta
blow in a [__] head with a bazooka
and not over the understanding and the
[__] take the deal or one of these
guys is trying to prove something you
see me trying to be [__] twin I don't
give a [__] I don't want to be 20 might
be 53 with a big big personality
chestnuts roasting on an open fire
[Music]
I got a bag of dead stars I could not
over a whole country to take all foreign
government but the daytime it's all
business one six seven thirty comes
that's when we go deep into the muck the
waters and the [__] on the world you
found me but since you're here and I got
you off your [__] high horse let's uh
let's smoke the little bone I believe
that yeah it's gonna be a [__] half
of Flagler your life you wanna smoke a
little boat we joke
another North farms growing some Gorilla
Biscuits number four
BAM
here we go right there
gonna fill this [__] up again
and that's it
like I said nice
you know I know what I am going in I'm
just out here with you guys it was last
time your uncle zip them up to the
garage they smoked the number talked
about your week that's all wrong though
nice little tool and maybe some lemon
juice
what happened whatever this is
I think I'm too [__] I'm still at 12
you ever get that [__] double-dealing
I can understand that said my my breath
was taken away but anyway I'm gonna be
at the Bray improv tonight to show 7 and
9:30 if you're not doing them come on
down completely like four stars before I
can't stay so anything could happen
take a chance Columbus did anybody go up
there with a [__] setlist and just
listen when I go up that go up there
just to [__] give you what I got what
I'm feeling through my life that's all
it's about
that's what stand-up is about everything
else but we you should be material so
the network's could give you a show suck
my dick and call me shorty if I wanted
to make money I'd be out there selling
blow get the gun robbing at the old
[__] fashioned way not mind the
[__] people at it it's not my style
but anyway you're not doing uncommon
Debray you're busy stay at home I would
good right with your family do what I'm
doing right now getting blasted to the
[__] diesels good at the end of the
day we just have a little chitchat here
oh yeah
I split those model
oh I see you [__] maybe later
maybe tomorrow morning yeah come on fly
well the church will get nice and stone
to the [__] gills all right beside
that uncle Joey loves you have a great
survey keep your [__] eyes open you
never know who's out there trying to
[__] do something you gonna walk down
looking at your [__] falling like a
jerk both some little [__] could be
flying by just calm down
zoom them on yet give me a little stab
and el culo and then he's off and there
you are walking around with an itchy
back [__] that [__] keep the eyes on
this young Joey talk until you're a
dealer [__] oh my god I got your so
Monica didn't come imagine her pain how
I came to know a Hoyo it feel to your
pingu buyer ping we don't know Pingu
poked at me seeking her for a big nah
that's just me [__] going off I'm
saying I love you [__] stay
back don't [__] give up and tell him
water shut get dick because either they
suck it tomorrow or they suck it next
Tuesday but then I get